they got rich and famous from the app
because it lets them sell other teens
crap and now they're richer than ceos
and that ce blows
the wall street journal owned by our
parent company twinkies
points out that some of tick tock's
biggest stars make more money than you
and some ceos so now you can feel like a
loser at your high school reunion and
their high school graduation
the top earner 17 year old charlie
dimillio made 17 million dollars last
year from a clothing line and selling
products on the app she has more than
130 million followers and earned more
than the median ceo salary of 13 million
although to be fair half of the teen's
followers were producers at cnn
her much older spinster sister 20 year
old dixie
is tick tock's second highest earner
raking in 10 million dollars in 2021 but
earn it well you can't dixie you old bag
her success like her sisters due to the
legions of young fans who will gladly
buy whatever they're hocking to make you
feel even worse seven of the t tick
tocks top earners say that fast made 55
million dollars last year that's almost
what i make in a month
so what's the moral of the story
get up off your butt download tick tock
dance around make millions it's not just
for young people anymore
when do i ask for the money
the money
when does
i think it's on uh hey everybody it's
it's joe devito and i'm here to show you
that you can make a lot of money on tick
tock even if you're a grown adult like
me so the technology is that
because you said you're going to be
helpful and what you're being is not
helpful because these filters are oh it
it's doing it's doing that thing again
no no it's not it's not funny because it
looks like there's something wrong with
me and i don't
i don't think you're going to make any
money joe what do you think
um i'm still waiting for those myspace
checks to come right again that's my
technology oh i have great stories yeah
it is um it's really sad but i it makes
me almost look forward to the impending
collapse of our financial system if it
just shuts down all these people because
we're wasting time with this and it's
setting the stage for the invasion
canada's been waiting 200 years and
we're going to see trudeau is going to
come riding right into washington and
he's going to be on an elephant wearing
his arabian nights makeup and we're
going to have nothing to say about it oh
god nobody to blame larry you are the
businessman here uh we should be
saluting these millionaire tick talkers
right yeah how much i love rich people
and i hope to make everybody rich even
tick-tockers but i gotta tell you i'm
not all that impressed because i know
that nancy pelosi this is according to
important websites nancy pelosi invested
55 million dollars of the year ending in
october and had a 69 rate of return
which is higher than anything bernie
madoff ever made and she did it without
any inside information whatsoever damn
that is some investment i mean she put
in 50 million she got 69 return better
than madoff and she never had any
insider information oh that's whatsoever
and not even from her son that's amazing
emily are you a tick tock
no you know why oh i hate this so much
because first of all it's we're talking
about the chinese government yes they
own it yes secondly i'm not 12. i don't
want to dance shame but watching them
makes me feel like a pedophile it's
disgusting and they are
horrible rich suck and they're making
millions over it even if you got rich
but you wouldn't dance a little but no
but she's making
how much you paying that's the one
i didn't mean that all right go ahead no
you're making a great point i know and
the ceo that analyzed everything said
that the reason that their fans are so
rabid is because these people
share
share things they said more than
hollywood celebs for example who are
more private that they draw in these
obsessive fans who will then buy
whatever they're selling because they
share things like breakups and triumphs
right i do that here on the show and it
works for me
i know and i'm only 40.
[Laughter]
emily's point that maybe the people that
are watching this are perverts old
perverts could that be or 12
or 12. i think that that could be
[Laughter]
absolutely yeah i mean i'm sure a
pervert would absolutely watch that yes
yeah i mean
right yes yeah yeah i saw his instagram
discovery page all teens
crazy but emily i just like you said
that she sucks which is very bold
because she's a child and i think you're
not supposed to say that about kids um
but i'll just say so i will say no she's
not she's old she's 17. i told so i'll
say
i am so proud of her success
as a woman
you go girl it is very inspiring to see
another young woman yes earn this what a
girl boss
right she's a girl boss
i may not make as much money as you but
you know am i happy also no
but i'm happy for you this is charlie
this is female 1
send me some money yeah this is
capitalism that is great i think they
call that a collab yeah there you go
yeah i will totally do a collab all
right i'm gonna throw up
me too up next did she have a death wish
for eating too much raw fish